daley gabbard is a former member of
congress from hawaii ran for president
last cycle she joins us tonight with her
assessment
congressman thanks so much for coming on
so given everything the country faces
right now
both domestically and abroad
why are the news networks colluding with
a political party to tell us this is the
most important thing
because whether you're talking about the
mainstream media or you're talking about
liz cheney adam kinzinger or congress
frankly
they don't carry they don't care about
the real threats that we face
domestically to our freedoms and our
democracy so instead they're focusing on
this they don't want to deal with the
real issues that americans are
struggling with every day across the
country
increasing inflation rising gas prices
uh increasing crime open borders the
list goes on and on about the the the
very real domestic issues uh that we
face and frankly they've abdicated on
their most important responsibility in
congress the one that constitution says
only congress has which is the power to
declare war or not so you know you've
talked about this tucker we just saw how
congress rushed through this additional
funding bill of 40 billion dollars
towards this war in ukraine we are we
are not only in a cold war with russia
we are in a hot war with russia with
ukraine as the proxy and there was no
serious debate whatsoever about really
what the consequences of this bill would
be and frankly whether or not we should
even be in a war with russia or frankly
any other country so this goes back to
what are their priorities every member
of congress takes an oath of office and
swears to support and defend the
constitution of the united states well
the constitution provides all of us with
very specific
rights and freedoms enshrined in that
constitution
right now we've got the biden
administration we've got the department
of justice the mainstream media big tech
all colluding to undermine our rights
and civil liberties and freedoms
i don't see congress taking action to
address and deal with that threat so if
they really wanted to uphold their oath
they swore
that's exactly what they should be
focused on right now
i think the most disturbing moment a
year and a half later looking back
is the moment where lindsey graham
turned to the capitol police and said
you have guns use them now they had just
shot an unarmed military veteran to
death who stood about five feet tall
and i guess what bothers me the most is
that nobody cared i mean police take
life
often it's justified we've defended it
on this show but to not investigate it
or explain it suggests that the life
that was taken was worth nothing
and that is the message that they're
sending this woman's life didn't mean
anything it wasn't we just killed her
and threw her away i mean how can
members of congress sit there and allow
that
members of congress are not again they
don't have their priorities straight
so much of this has been politicized
it's been sensationalized with very
specific objectives that have nothing to
do with upholding the constitution or
what's in the best interest of the
country and the american people and i
think the way that this hearing is has
been
actually not even so-called produced
it's literally being produced by
somebody i think who is from abc news in
order to try to come with an out you
know with an objective that has nothing
to do again with what's best for the
people uh what's best for the
constitution they're they're trying to
achieve their own political interests um
and it and it's just really sad that
they're abusing their power in order to
do that
this is the kind of propaganda show that
we used to make fun of when it took
place in totalitarian when you were a
kid you remember that i mean yeah we had
this vibrant lively news media and
people debated things and we look over
at these totalitarian hell holes and say
you know they turn on their tvs and they
get this pre-produced lying
how shocking is this it this is not
america and this is what's so crazy and
and what's angering and sad all of these
things at the same time is this is not
the vision that our founders had for
america and these people who serve
in the people's house members of
congress literally go to work every day
in the people's house and it just seems
like so many of them have forgotten that
that's who they work for that it's such
a privilege to have that responsibility
i'm grateful to have had it uh and and
to see them going every day and just and
abusing that privilege abusing that
responsibility and not at all focused on
what's in the best interest of the
people
should be concerning for every american
across the country and that's why we
have elections we have the opportunity
to fire those who are not putting the
american people in our country first i
think this every time we talk you're one
of the most temperamentally moderate and
sensible and even-keeled people i've
ever talked to and you were considered a
radical
the congress it just tells you
everything about them
we're always grateful when you're on
tulsa gabriel thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight